[Musique]
leona
bats toi qui comprend l'harmonie de ce
monde de ces proportions
oui il va falloir que tous les humains
de toute la planète suivent mes rêves
m oui c'est moi le même
[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous bonjour alors
aujourd'hui nous parlons de métrologie
c'est l'étude du macho mais non jeune
humoriste la métrologie c'est la science
de la mesure c'est une discipline certes
peu connu du grand public et pourtant
c'est un des piliers de notre
civilisation
aujourd'hui on va essayer de comprendre
pourquoi
sans la mesure et la métrologie qui
l'accompagnent il n'ya pas d'horloge pas
de gps pas de cartographie pas de double
des six matches et pas de science et ce
n'est pas tout quand on regarde tous les
pays toutes les cultures du monde
moderne et bien on ne partage pas la
même langue
bon j'adore on ne partage pas la même
musique
on ne partage pas la même cuisine mais
on partage tous les mêmes unités de
mesure
mais quand on y pense c'est quand même
un gros truc de malade le libéria et
puis les etats-unis qui n'ont pas adopté
le système métrique
c'est vrai mais leurs unités sont quand
même calqué sur les mêmes unités du
système international
et pour info mon cher charles on ne dit
plus du système métrique
tous les pays doivent donc se coordonner
pour avoir tous le même kilo de la même
seconde même degré ça peut vous paraître
bien compliqué tout ça mais mais il ya
de bonnes raisons de se donner autant de
peine bref pourquoi et comment mesurer
le monde pour trouver des éléments de
réponse
nous allons discuter avec lui s'il
julien lé physicienne au laboratoire lkb
elle nous expliquera pourquoi la quête
de précision dans les mesures n'est pas
uniquement pour la beauté du geste
elle reviendra sur la définition de
quatre unités de mesure car oui en effet
en cette année 2010 8 l'humanité change
la définition du kg entre aude pardon
nous irons également dans les
laboratoires souterrains de
l'observatoire de paris et chercheurs
travaillent sur la mesure du temps
ils sont en train de développer les
horloges atomiques du futur tellement
précises qu'elles nous permettront
peut-être un jour de tester les lois
fondamentales de notre univers oh ouais
mais tout d'abord j'ai un rendez vous
télévisuel avec bernadette bensaude
vincent elle est philosophe et
historienne elle travaille notamment sur
le rapport entre mesure et connaissances
mesure les justice sociale mesure et
environnement bonjour bernadette
j'ai l'impression que les humains
passent leur temps à mesurer le monde
qui les entoure pourquoi pourquoi et
bien parce que la mesure est utile dans
toute la vie quotidienne et dans tous
les aspects de la vie c'est à dire que
l'on mesure la quantité d'électricité
caunes est en train de dépenser leur
communiqué au moins juqu'à vitesse pour
éviter deux points ou en pvc charles
dumont mesure le taux d'audimat la
télévision là est la fonction de ça ça
sert de critère la mesure sert de
critère pour déterminer les impôts c'est
un outil de justice sociale ok donc
fondamentalement ça permet de répartir
les biens de calculer l'impôt mais si on
prend du recul
la mesure nous est surtout permis de
bâtir le monde moderne celui que l'on
connaît aujourd'hui
la mesure est quelque chose qui
interviennent beaucoup et dans les
techniques
plus encore que dans les sciences parce
que il faut beaucoup beaucoup de mesure
alors la très très précises pour
fabriquer des machines pour un bâtiment
pour pour doser médicaments même pour
faire des accusés oui si on veut faire
de la bonne cuisine attrait pour faire
de la bonne cuisine il faut quelques
temps de grave que ceux ci tentent de
krav de cela plus un geste de défiance
[Applaudissements]
voilà il faut il faut en tout cas
toujours un petit peu mais c'est du
qualitatif même c'était la presse avoir
pressé mais il faut de la mesure dans
toute opération technique et il faut en
tout cas de la mesure c'est le principe
fondamental de la justice sociale c'est
que il faut que les choses soient
proportionnées mesure est donc une
proportion assez profond ça pour mesurer
le monde
il faut constamment le comparer à
quelque chose une unité de base il
existe cette unité fondamentale à partir
desquels on peut décrire le monde qui
nous entoure
chers amis c'est à vous alors je vous
présente pour l'intensité électrique
la molle pour la quantité de matières le
nombre d'atomes par exemple le match
bien entendu pour les distances le
kelvin pour la température trois
secondes pour le temps là candela pour
l'intensité lumineuse et le kg pour la
basse en cette fin d'année 2010 8
l'humanité a changé sa définition de
quatre de ses unités lampert la molle le
kelvin et le kg
mais pourquoi changer de définition pour
te répond mon cher charles
prenez l'exemple du kilogramme vous
allez voir pourquoi il était urgent de
faire quelque chose jusqu'à présent le
kg était définie par rapport à un objet
physique et le voici un cylindre créée
en 1889 avec un alliage de platine et
d'iridium toutes les choses que l'on
veut peser sur terre votre alter en
salle de sport
le kilo de crevettes vendus sur un petit
marché en thaïlande sont comparés à ce
petit cylindre qui se trouvent en france
c'est le kg avec un grand cas
senti non le grand cas on l'appelle
aussi qu'à 0 0 car une quarantaine de
copies ont été créés et disséminés un
peu partout dans le monde afin qu'il n'y
ait pas si je puis me permettre
deux poids deux mesures oui mais
pourquoi changer de définition j'y
arrive mon petit pour répondre à cette
question je vais appeler lucile du lien
physicienne au lkp un laboratoire
spécialisé notamment dans la métrologie
bonjour lucile tu vas bien bonjour du
hasard ça fait longtemps je t'ai pas vu
carrément alors je t'appelle parce qu'on
fait un épisode sur la mesure et les
unités de mesure
j'ai vu qu'il va falloir redéfinir le
kilo pourquoi c'est quoi le problème
avec le kg aujourd'hui
alors à l'heure actuelle bon on dit le
kilo et c'est le kilogramme bien sûr le
kilogramme est très différent des autres
unités
parce qu'il est défini à partir d'un
prototype matériel qui est un objet en
platini rivier et qui est déposé à
sèvres au bureau et un dessert les poids
et mesures
c'est en banlieue parisienne c'est ça
ambühl et parisienne voilà et c'est le
seul prototype qui reste pour définir
une unité à l'origine il avait également
le maître étalon
il a été abandonné depuis longtemps une
barre de métal exactement en platine
héritiers donc en 1889
on a fait un programme et un maître en
platine riediennes pour la masse et pour
la longueur mais lemaitre a été
abandonnée en 1960 ce maître étalon
oui aujourd'hui le naître est définie
par la distance parcourue par la lumière
en une fraction de seconde et un étalon
matériel et bien ça peut être perdu ça
peut être abîmée il peut lui arriver une
catastrophe peut y avoir une guerre
donc c'est quelque chose qui est fragile
et qu'on ne peut pas reproduire si
j'avais les perdus
je ne suis pas sûr de comprendre
quel est le problème si on le perd on
leur fait tranquille assure qu'on a fait
avec lui on pourra pas le comparer aux
mesures qu'on fera avec la nouveau
prototype on aura toujours un doute
un prototype sera différent tandis que
quand on fait une horloge à ses yeux
main pour donner la seconde
eh bien on peut la faire partout on fait
son horloge de césium dans son
laboratoire et c'est la même seconde
ok mais si on ne peut plus utiliser une
masse de référence qu'est ce qu'on peut
utiliser de plus stable alors donc on
peut trouver un objet qui n'a pas été
réalisé par les humains un objet qui est
là dans la nature et qui dont on pense
que les vraiment stable indépendant de
nous et de notre réalisation par exemple
la région de prototypes ont mal elle est
forcément imparfaite
qu'en dit qu'il y avait des choses à la
nature dont on pense qu'elles sont fixes
une constante quoi du coup quel
constante va définir le kg alors la
constante qui va être caché là dans la
définition du kilogramme c'est la
constante de planck
c'est une constante important de la
physique qui joue un rôle prépondérant
pour tout ce qui est les phénomènes
quantiques
voilà donc la constante de planck est la
constante de la physique quantique mais
c'est de toute beauté
quand je vais peser mon kilos de patates
il va être liées à la physique quantique
max est exactement
exactement et cette constante de planck
va aussi jouer un rôle clé pour les
unités électriques donc la métrologie
c'est une science particulièrement lié
au quotidien mais mais mais il me semble
qu'elle vous sert également pour
d'autres types de mesures
oui alors sous le mois métrologie bien
se cache différents visages la
métrologie quotidienne jeu qui ment
quand vous achetez votre essence à la
pompe à essence
il faut être sûr que le litre qu'on vous
vend ce sont vraiment du litre donc ça
c'est important il faut que la poupée
kate a le nez ça c'est la vie
quotidienne
et puis dans la métrologie vu par les
chercheurs comme dans notre équipe nous
mesurerons avec une très grande
précision pour aller comment dire
traquer les théories physiques dans
leurs derniers retranchements
oui on va en parler mais revenons aux
unités et leur définition plus de cette
redéfinition des unités c'est que tous
les pays souhaitant peut mettre de
l'homme vu leur nom c'est en france ce
que son nez le maître et le kg au moment
de la révolution française et donc il y
avait derrière ce m 6 kg un idéal
d'universalité que portait de
révolutionnaires français
l'idéal d'universalité des
révolutionnaires portait sur tous les
humains on avait défini le m
à partir du méridien terrestre pour
qu'il soit pour tous les tous les hommes
de la terre maintenant modifiera les
unités à partir des constantes
fondamentales de la physique
c'est quelque chose qui va bien au delà
de notre terre si un jour nous
rencontrions des êtres extraterrestres
nous pourrions leur expliquer nos unités
de mesure qui pourrait comprendre et on
sera nous aussi sur la même longueur
d'onde
en un sens oui puisque nous avons choisi
des objets qui ne sont pas liées
spécifiquement à notre bonne vieille
terre
merci le cil si on doit commercer avec
des civilisations extraterrestres
on sera bien préparé lucile julien a
commencé à nous parler de l'utilité de
la métrologie pour pousser les limites
de nos théories physiques
c'est grâce notamment à une mesure du
temps de plus en plus précises que l'on
peut étudier des phénomènes qui se
déroule très vite dans le temps on peut
le boire dans un reportage du cnrs sur
les nouveaux maîtres du temps et
scientifiques travaillent sur le
développement d'horloges atomiques
encore plus précise que celle
d'aujourd'hui
enfin il faudrait plutôt dire plus exact
pro garder la quête de précision n'est
pas près de s'arrêter
et c'est dans les souterrains de
l'observatoire de paris que les
chercheurs inventent les horloges
atomiques du futur dans cette horloge et
plus précise mais les plus jeunes donc
pour pouvoir remplacer les archers des
hommes il faut que qu'elle gagne en
maturité ont plus à faire fonctionner 24
heures sur 24 7 jours sur 7 et qu'elle
puisse être liée aux autres horloges qui
sont développés dans les autres
laboratoires de métrologie le césium
pourrait bien se faire détrôner par le
strontium qui bat dix mille fois plus
rapidement
alors qu'il faudrait 100 millions
d'années pour qu'une horloge au césium
glisse d'une seconde
une horloge astronomes elle garderait le
rythme pendant dix milliards d'années
des horloges tellement puissante que les
chercheurs espèrent pouvoir les utiliser
un jour pour tester avec une nouvelle
précision les lois fondamentales de la
physique la théorie de base de la fidic
s'appelle le modèle standard donc c'est
cette théorie qui décrire toutes les
particules d'interaction et il y à il ya
des observations astronomiques qui
remette en cause mon maître à défaut ce
modèle standard en introduisant de
nouvelles particules mais l'énergie
qu'on appelle énergie noire une matière
noire et grâce aux horloges qui
mesurerait le temps très très précises
on peut observer des tout petits défauts
dans la physique actuelle et si elle
valide et ses théories qui vont au delà
du modèle stream donc pourquoi mesurer
le monde parce que c'est en mesurant ce
qui nous entoure que l'on découvre ses
secrets c'est aussi grâce à la mesure
que l'on peut fabriquer tous les
éléments de notre monde moderne et
comment mesurer le monde
et bien grâce aux unités qui sont
redéfinies régulièrement au rythme de
nos avancées technologiques
aujourd'hui nos unités sont enfin toutes
basées sur des constantes de l'univers
en s'appuyant sur ces nouvelles
définitions nous pourrons faire des
mesures toujours plus précises
ça peut vous sembler réservé aux
laboratoires de recherche c'est vrai
mais c'était pareil il y à 50 ans
lorsque la seconde a été définie selon
les vibrations d'un atome de césium et
cette mesure du temps ultra précise nous
permet aujourd'hui de faire fonctionner
nos gps nos microprocesseurs et tous nos
échanges par internet
alors que va nous apporter une mesure
ultrafin kg duquel bing ou de lampes r
pour l'instant on ne le sait pas encore
mais ce qui est sûr c'est que ça nous
ouvre des portes vers de nouvelles
découvertes et en même temps et ça me
rassure
ça montre que parfois tous les pays
peuvent se mettre d'accord sur une chose
dans le but de faire avancer les causes
de l'humanité qui je mesure mes mots à
bientôt
[Musique]
bon